gary was telling me he had the worst two
weeks of his life what yeah I tried to
cheer him up I said I said to Gary you
know here's your problem your problem is
you have good weeks you should be like
man every week is a bad week and I never
I don't feel anything because I just
expect it to be bad Rob and I said to
Howard I go do nothing good happened on
this vacation it goes now some of the
good things happen I go but no good days
he goes no no full days no not of cold
day well whole day of good good this is
so crazy anyway what's going on with you
I'm concerned and the short version is
that I'm having a knee replacement in
early August I've you know I literally
have no cartilage left in either knee
and now it turns out that I have what
they call Robin never even heard of an
insufficient fracture oh I guess it I
guess it happens when there's no
quarters left right and they brand they
break
fracture it's been so nuts I've been
trying to do everything but I'm not I
won't take pain killers so they put me
on some Balta which is an antidepressant
which I thought was really weird but
apparently I look the National arthritis
Society says it works really well
but there's nothing worse than putting
someone who isn't depressed to an
antidepressant because I think it made
me depressed and now I really know I
sleep I slept almost all the vacation I
slept late every day I would take naps
in the middle of the day how do you get
around you're not are you using a walker
or anything
no no but getting getting up and down if
you saw me going up and down the stairs
you would [ __ ] laugh it takes me
about a minute to get down a flight of
stairs I have to hold onto the banisters
and you know bring my and then I go up
one step at a time you know what you
ought to get you know that thing on TV
that chair that carries you up the
stairs yeah it's my big serving tray how
many doctor visits did you go on for
your knee surgery okay so I need a total
of seven visits to get the surgery I had
to go on four so the first one was the
dentist the next one was my primary the
third one was the heart surgeon the
fourth one was an MRI for your knee
surgery had to go to the dentist yes and
I asked why and the guy said that um the
biggest problem with the knee surgery is
infection and that some people who
that the hygiene could have an infection
in their mouth and I could go through
your bloodstream and could [ __ ] up the
surgery so they just need to get a
sign-off that your have a good dental
health and yes I do have good dental
health Robin I know what you he knows
what you're thinking because I was
thinking the same thing yeah you better
be careful Gary now who did your hair
Mary I'm up like feeling mohawk going on
or something no no no hey you know the
guys pretty down Robin hey Gary you say
to me I hear Gary can barely walk let me
goof on his haircut
you